let's bring in dar lief he's sheriff of
berry County Michigan sheriff thanks for
coming in you're one of the sheriff's
who's saying look I'm not gonna listen
to Governor Whitmer I'm gonna defy the
order why we're not saying we're not
gonna listen to governor Whitmore we're
going to use common sense when it comes
to enforcing it when people are being
respectful and using that six foot range
and we're not going to go out and start
telling people to go home you know look
we have a lot of people out Hastings
here that are walking we have a lot of
people who want to go out and do some
fishing there at home and we have an
order right now that you can have a
kayak you can have a canoe but you can't
have a motorboat well I want people out
of their hosts we have an uptick of
domestics and from our 9-1-1 center and
I want people to get out on gets
stretched and get away from the house
what better place then out in the middle
of the lake and nobody's around you
mm-hmm
understand governor Whitmer was on ABC
this morning and seemed to dismiss some
of what you just said and said this is
all about saving lives watch for chair
side of 83 sheriff's making a point
that's fine you know and I can take it
if it makes people feel better to take
their frustrations on I mean the fact of
the matter is it's better to be six feet
apart right now than six feet under and
that is the whole point of this we've
got to save lives every life matters yes
sir what's he saying please about you
know look this is about saving lives
which I'm assuming you clearly want to
do and you made that clear in your first
answer as well but she was dismissive
she said this is four out of eighty
three sheriff's and they're just making
basically a political point that
political it's more common sense again
if somebody's out in the middle of a
lake and away from everybody over there
on their lawn mower and they're 100
yards away from people that's where we
want them we don't want them bottled up
inside the house where they start
arguing and started drinking alcohol and
I think that's reasonable sheriff you're
on the front lines of this do you feel
like the pendulum is swinging a bit that
at the beginning and there were some
justifiable reasons to make sure that
health and safety came first but that
now
maybe some things have gone too far and
people are standing up for their rights
yes I agree with some of that the that
curve they're talking about is
flattening and right now in Barre County
we are in the kind of the peak of what
they said was going to the wave that was
going to hit Barry County a week ago we
had seven that were positive one that
was recovered and we had one death now
we're up to about 16 and this was
yesterday I didn't check today's numbers
yet today we're up to 16 still have the
one death and we have I think two or
three that have recovered from it well
we certainly hope that curve continues
to flatten not just in Michigan but all
across this great country we've been
thanking the health care workers are on
the front lines you and all first
responders and law enforcement on the
front lines as well we want to thank you
for your service sir and thanks for
sharing your views I thank you I want
everybody to respect the health workers
and all that if you can't stand at home
stay at home but if you need to get out
walk out we're not going to bother you
on that if you need to go walk get out
of Bowl so some people are even hopped
on their quads and going on some of the
back roads you know very Coney we're not
going to bother going up
thanks again Sheriff Sandra all right
thank you